et vous ne pensez pas que c'est
dangereux pour jeunes filles de me
reçoit saint lambert parmi tous ces
garçons vous pouvez me faire le portrait
du garçon qui vient généralement je
croix saint lambert pour traiter à we
still il a dû cheveux longs un blouson
un pantalon en cuir ou même le blouson
est en cuir pantalons pattes d'éléphant
chaussée aux bottes exactement très
calme il ya quatre ans la presse montées
en épingle avec une certaine
complaisance quelques actes de violence
commis par deux jeunes garçons identifié
aussitôt à des blousons noirs à des
tricheurs des sanctions furent prises
elles n'ont pas empêché que le square
saint lambert dans le 15e arrondissement
à paris demeure le lieu de rencontre de
toute une jeunesse turbulente inquiète
et comme repliée sur elle-même certes
les actes de violences ont cessé
mais il n'en reste pas moins que la
présence cet immense bande de jeunes où
se mêlent bon et moins bon et dont le
nombre certains soirs appel cavailles
dépasse la centaine pose un grave
problème
nous n'avons pas la prétention de le
résoudre mais nous avons pensé que nous
pouvions contribué à sa solution en vous
faisant mieux connaître ces garçons
[Musique]
yves je crois que vous êtes en quelque
sorte le roi de ce poisson lambert
ajoutant celui vous est menée depuis
longtemps lui disant qu'il a je vous
avais 17 ans et combien de fois avez
vous au square saint lambert
ben tout de suite après que j'ai fini le
travail je viens ici à 6 ans puisque
l'os quoi il fini à 6 ans et demi tous
les soirs tous les soirs peu près tous
les soirs et vos parents sont d'accord
mais on veut bien une condition que pas
la police qui viennent ici depuis
combien de temps l'homme neige face à
l'envers 20 depuis l'âge de 4 ans depuis
l'âge de 4 ans on y est vous y passait
des journées presse entière souffrirait
oui souvent pourquoi parce que je ne
travaillais pas bah oui en ce moment oui
je travaille pas en ce moment on
s'occupe de moi là justement pour une
place à ce rythme jusqu'au je connais
c'est la musique la musique ma mère
qu'elle entend parler de la musique à
d'un folk et quel genre de musique elle
madison le twist ou alors à tout ce qui
est à la mode
et pourquoi vous aimez ce blouson on
parce qu'il ya un peu remarquable il
entend confier au square or ya un an
quand même et vous avez des quartiers
dans l'ancienne rue saint-charles et a
longtemps vous habitez le quartier mais
ça fait saison et vous n'étiez jamais
venu avance ou non
pourquoi en rajouter un peu plus
sérieuses maintenant ah bon parce que
quand on vient au square on est plus
sérieux ainsi mr on aime bien
accompagner les copains le serbe faisait
lui rend un peu pareil
quel âge vous avez 18 ans et demi qu'est
ce que vous faites je fais juste rôtir
et vos parents qu'est ce qu'ils font à
mon grand père il travaille de nuit ma
grand mère se refuse c'est eux qui nous
ont élevés que vous n'avez plus vos
parents n'ont écrivez vos os x sales
envers tous les soirs tous les soirs
quand je quitte mon boulot et samedi
ce lundi toute la journée parce que je
travaille pas de salut il dit moi je
sors avec une camarade j'ai un problème
ah bon mais la camarade avec laquelle
vous sortez dimanche le fréquente
personne n'aurait osé pour le square
puis moi je m'habille comme il faut je
suis je pour paris il faut mettre en
confiance et deux enfants dansent
ensemble deux ans vous êtes ensemble
et alors vous revenez vous voulez tous
les deux ensemble espace à lombers ah
oui oui mais alors devenir seul
maintenant non non pourquoi
parce que c'est pas la foi venir seul si
je viens je l'emmène avec moi je peux
laisser tout seul et je prends confiance
m'a laissé tout seul et c'est quand cela
m'a fallu parler correctement quand même
quoi puis malet chose qu'il dit et tout
cela regarde pas on entre camarades ça
notre camarade parle entre nous elle a
là rien à voir là dedans
est ce que vous faites vous ces
nouvelles techniques vigée lebrun
mais les gentils qui viennent de se
rassembler sans l'agencé sérieuses comme
vous on va ça n'est pas tout
y aller on les sélectionne
il y en a qui ne sont pas sérieux ça se
respecte est ce pour ça mais vous vous
avez su vous citez ghanéen prochaine on
lui dit non non ça va bonjour bonjour
camarades camarades c'est tout c'est pas
dangereux pour un garçon d'avenir au
soir à l'envers ça dépend si le garçon a
le tempérament il peut venir mais sont
faciles à paul tant que ramos lui
conseille point de venir
qu'est ce que c'est pour voir des
tempéraments c'est-à-dire unis
risqueraient de se faire entraîner pour
ma paroisse disons que je me suis laissé
entraîner quelques points en tout temps
ça vous a posé les ennuis grave non
trouveront pas trop grave et vous
mademoiselle qu'est ce que vous faites
soit 120 vers moi je viens parce que
nixon après quoi vous êtes lycéenne
assistant puis en quelle place en 3e
quels sont ils réellement ces jeunes
c'est aux adultes que nous avons posé
cette question aux adultes qui chaque
jour les rencontres les côtoie tout
d'abord au gardien du square ne sont pas
bien à craindre quand même parce que
sont depuis gars qui veulent se donner
un petit peu de celles et ceux qui
travaillent tous ces gars qui viennent
ici en a qui travaillent il travaillait
qui travaillent le service de nuit d'eau
typhon à 3,8 alors il arrive que des
fois ils sont là le matin ou dans
l'après midi
c'est à ce moment là quand y en a
d'autres petits ils ne foutent rien
alors cela il débouche les emmène entre
mai puis c'est là qu'ils font d'habitude
une doctoresse qui est en même temps
mère de famille a voulu aider ces jeunes
elle les reçoit dans son foyer
écoutez la ils ont l'air heureux de ne
pas pouvoir s'intégrer dans la société
couach ça colle pas ils ont ils ce
qu'ils disent
ils disent tous j'en ai marre j'en ai
marre en règle générale pourquoi ne
travaille pas
bien parce que ça d'abord ils ont pas pu
faire la plupart du temps ce qu'il
aurait aimé faire parce que c'était il
fallait trouver de l'argent
il avait la famille on n'avait pas les a
mis au travail
alors ils ont près du boulot pour
prendre du boulot puis souvent parce que
les patrons ne sont pas toujours très
compréhensifs est-ce que vos parents sa
tournée au ska saint lambert
oui oui le fabriquer ce qu'ils font vos
parents ma mère ne travaille pas et mon
père travaille comme madoff
vous avez des frères des soeurs oui oui
combien vous êtes chez nous on est 8 8
ayé mes parents lui tailler vos parents
vous vivez dans combien de pièces dans
deux pièces
autrement dit vous n'avez qu'une idée
c'est de sortir peut-être oui c'est ça
et quand vous sortez vos menus au choix
saint-lambert ça oui par moments des
fois on a des petits coups de cafard pas
du tout comme ça parce que des fois je
suis avec eux je suis avec mon beau-père
main à un mariage chez moi alors des
fois que cette dispute un peu à la
maison alors je m'en vais presser pour
ça qu'est ce que vous faites alors qu'en
plus avez le cafard comme ça
baj je viens au square souvent et puis
alors je vais me promener quoi ça l'est
pour raconter aux camarades du sport non
non pas du tout non non vous m'aviez dit
que vous aviez fait des bêtises
comment vous avez fait la maison vous
entraîner à faire ces bêtises là pour
montrer et puis après après j'ai pris un
peu tout seul parce que ça pour apporter
de l'argent ces vélos se trouve aux
portes parce que rien
aussi dira oh rien et puis en fin de
compte et saez et vous risquez beaucoup
n'ont savini c'est tout
et alors pourquoi vous les fassiez on
pense que le temps passe que vous n'avez
rien d'autre à faire je crois même que
vous avez à fleur d'eau au soir le jeune
homme là que j'aperçois avec lala de la
veste en velours au oui/non
c'est sérieux pourquoi pas il a l'air de
le prendre au sérieux moussy m'enfin je
vous avez jusqu'à 20 qu'est ce qui vous
a plu en lui souhaitant un peu touche
pas et qu'est ce qui vous déplaît
c'est à dire que j'ai bien aimé halle
avec lui je voulais le mettre dans le
droit chemin du studio ça marchera
peut-être pas parce que l'idée les
enfants à leur manière qu'est-ce que
vous avez très exactement mais il
travaillait pas alors je vais lui
demander de travailler alors elle et qui
cherchent une place mais pourquoi ne
travaillez pas aux vins ça l'embêtait de
se lever le matin et ses parents lui
disait rien mais s'il fait une super
débarque chez lui
quel âge il a 18 ans et alors qu'est ce
que vous lui dites encore qu'est ce
qu'on lui reprochait encore hommes sont
habillement parce que j'aime pas
tellement les pattes d'éléphant depuis
la canadienne à la moutte alors il m'a
dit bon ben je la revends et plus
aujourd'hui comme l'hypnose kaimah du
monde hachés vendus maman il arrive
qu'on dort du square saint lambert
on cherche à se distraire tout
naturellement va au cinéma et tout
naturellement ont choisi les films de
violence et en dehors du soir qu'est ce
que vous avez comme distraction sim vous
allez souvent cinéma ah oui oui c'est
bon vous allez dans tous les cinémas où
à peu près tous et parce que vous êtes
bien sûr ça dépend quelques fois
lorsqu'on est mal habillé bon souviens
qu'une fois on s'était fait vider d'un
cinéma quoi où ça moi je préfère pas
cité le nom c'est comment vous étiez à
billets alors comment on peut appeler en
voyou qui commençait à être habillé
envoyer ou alors ça dépend de l'ethnie
général classe
vous savez on pourrait décrire simple la
fête foraine du boulevard pasteur
la fête à pasteur comme ils disent est
aussi pour ces jeunes un grand pôle
d'attraction plaisir d'enfant facile
étourdissant au milieu des bruits et des
cris ils oublient leur inadaptation au
monde qui les entoure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
venez mon exemple de cotisants vainement
autre bombe entre bandrés certaines
frictions entre bruit entre la bande du
square saint lambert
quelle bande c'est de la porte devant
wicked reflets mais alors qu'est ce qui
se passe vous battez ou quoi ben oui
sérieusement ça fait mal
mais quelle est la réaction de la police
quand il ya des histoires comme ça quand
un des chefs du globe
à ce moment-là et conques et la réaction
aux parents ne sont au courant ils sont
jamais au courant relou non jamais mais
comment comptent ils font pas être au
courant
il vous demande pas ce que vous faites
le soir de votre travail ou le samedi et
dimanche si si mais je leur racontant
que vaut mieux se passe quand air que
vous vous battez avec la porterai en
dépit du cinéma de la foire des bagarres
on s'ennuie ferme et à longueur de
journée puisque on ne travaille pas on
cherche ce qu'on pourrait bien faire
encore alors on se rend au café le seul
café du quartier qui valent bien les
recevoir
vous avez déjà fait des bêtises
françois houle qu'est ce que ça fait un
club et y trompent tout poste me suis
battu enfin étrangers j'ai insulté des
personnes
et pourquoi vous faisiez comme ça quoi
un comble pour me rendre intelligent
quoi faire le garçon qui va se prendre
pointe à ypres l'ajustement allez vous
étiez un peu le cas ils qui se passe à
lambert proto allemand
maintenant on raconte même saveur vous
avez tout de même une certaine autorité
sur votre pain un peuple qu'est ce que
vous leur conseiller surtout de fins
dopantes faire comme il y avait avant
que quand c'est tout insulter les gens
et tout ça parce que ça ne rapporte rien
vous l'avez compris le problème est
grave
le square saint lambert n'est pas un cas
isolé dans toute la france dans tous les
milieux des jeunes
déséquilibrée par les conditions de la
vie moderne ont besoin qu'on les aide
il faut agir et agir vite
[Musique]